what where did we get to last time I
can't remember it's been a week that's a
long time you guys gonna have to help me
out here you over
cool I got loads of unlockables
Leon moves swiftly through the police
station's basement but encounters a
grotesque monster standing his back mr.
axe
devoid of its pom humanity I don't know
what the hell and also um other dudes
still alive down here is named mm-hmm
wait okay this is my stuff like this is
when we gets difficult guys so I'm not
gonna lie over the week I was kind of
like missing this game so I read up
about mr. X and I was like can you kill
him no you can't so there's no point we
have to just go around yeah it's gonna
be interesting apparent if you stay in
the same place for too long he comes to
get ya also if you make too much noise
he comes to get ya so the best thing to
do is to try and avoid conflict try and
not kill things cuz he hears you
shooting as well so I think we can do
that I'm quite good at running away from
my problems yeah anyway Oh God Jesus
Christ wait how do i okay so I just need
to get my bearings let me get my ball
bearings what do I have do I have the
heart key yeah like what what my god
I've got the clover key
[Music]
because I remember I found a place with
some random cogs and stuff but I think I
need one more cog all these bedrooms
mean there's something that I can pick
up but there's nothing if there's
anything important it should show up and
obviously I haven't been in here yet how
do I get there you have to bear with me
guys I have to get all my ball bearings
back my ball bearings but we're looking
for fuses aren't we safe in there
I left chronically locked door oh yeah
cuz there's this PC living here dongle
for
hey Nathan
oh look gearbox and there's a large gear
here in the clock tower is that why I
was then just now I think it is there's
no more clovers yeah there's gotta be
because the key is still useful
apparently hmm
all right I have not a bloody clue part
door
[Music]
electronic door all the doors
hmm okay but where the hell is mr. [ __ ]
this I'll just lick it this way though
right I go this way okay guys I think
I'm just gonna die I can't be bought no
no no I'm not gonna die isn't gay right
I'm gonna go the long way back again
don't hurt me I'm only a little girl
going to the toilet I don't know why I'm
in here
um yeah so if we get to these stairs and
we can get up I guess maybe that again
ah oh yeah come out
hey where is he
see I don't matter if this audio is like
sounds like he's coming from where
you're about to go oh [ __ ] all right
yeah mr. X is it coming wait did I have
I been in that room before that one up
that yeah that's the saber okay
okay now we're back in the basement
again I know there's something down here
except for maybe dogs so I'm gonna go
back up this way
yeah the freakin dogs are still here let
me alone I know once you ah they did
they just stayed there good dogs
I am the dog whisperer okay
to get back up to get back up what do we
need
I think oh no we're done with this oh my
god I went all this way I don't actually
think I can okay to save time I'm going
to just unload my game again I was just
gonna go back around again cuz mr. X is
there but oh I don't know where I'm to
go I think I need to go back up to that
clock tower again yeah I think I need to
go there cuz it's show that there was a
cold fair but I thought I'd place them
all down in the right places but I was
kind of freaking out about mr. X so I
probably didn't do the right thing okay
so let's just do this quickly because
mr. X is coming please
oh so the door was it that way racing
very amazing oh yeah fricken key I don't
have another cool hat oh no that's not
hot that was this girl dude mind forget
that I said anything don't know where
else I can use the code the key floor
but did I go upstairs or downstairs
before nope haven't gone downstairs
okay right this might mean focus I think
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] mr. X hands up okay okay
this looks like something that I could
use with something that I don't have on
me right now so I need to get back to my
box whoo
okay let's take some time out let's read
something
why is this still noises happening I
thought the game is paused okay let me
know if like there's any discrepancies
with the audio I can turn the game up if
you want me to I don't like these noises
and hey Becca and hey Montez hey
el-banna Rock hey James out here hey
everyone
Morrison Oh Morrison said he can't chase
you into the Stars office that where I
am now yeah hope so stop making the
freaking noises but anyway um reason for
a confiscation confiscation a suspicious
man was found at a local at the location
listed above when confronted by an
officer he tried to escape by acting
confused that sounds like something I
would do I'm just I don't know why I
tried to be Mickey Mouse though I know
he had on him was confiscated it's not
like everyone doesn't know who it is but
it's Justin Hanson age 39 city resident
single and a regular fixture in our Jail
he wasn't a bad guy per se just a bit of
a bad brain kleptomaniac can't believe
you tried to pull a fast one in the
police station of all places though
there's a scuff paper in a plastic bag
6 to 1 so this is 2 second floor waiting
burn 6 2 1 6 to 11 okay yup yup yup
nice nice nice oh no this is just an
observation room so screw it
you can definitely come in here and I
should definitely be worried and not
taking my time but I'm still taking my
time cuz I'm an idiot like that way
let's go at least this room is locked
I'm just waiting for him I'm like I'm
sure he's outside like I'm just waiting
for him to come in that way work the
room come in the room that's a big
pretty gross oh of course this is the
interrogation room
um nothing's gonna happen is it's not
gonna come in here oh we're just realize
captain Tosen Storen earrings aren't the
key it's fine I'm locked in a dead end
anyway I can't save my god
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm knocked his hat off and I can't
achievement for it yes but oh here yeah
yeah right
no nope nope where is
I should have gone oh it doesn't matter
now what's done is done
oh okay we survived guys we spray away
survive let's get to our box hey baby
where the [ __ ] is he coming from did he
just teleport
I got an electronic part I might need
that
okay we got a lot of ammo anyways so
bucket is coming where is he where is he
like I can hear him but I have no clue
where he is it's freaking me out
[Music]
wait can he not come in here is this the
stars office actually don't know already
hey welcome to the stream you know what
I don't think I've died yet very crazy
stars
special baggage to the RPD special
closes division nice special tactics and
Rescue Service
dude okay we got the dongle key it's
just gonna say that we don't have it
okay so that means that we need to go
upstairs great thinkers watching with
his morning coffee hope you enjoy let's
combine always together
it produces dumbest shakin and gods
against poison why do I need I'm not
gonna be poisoned all right okay hey
buddy I like that guy right oh my god I
thought I was a dog freaked me out for a
second where am I going
it's okay Leon you've got a lil bit of
house stop en cetera
just walk slowly they won't hear me
amazing oh it's so cute okay okay we
should have taken out the ammo for this
guy as we got a bunch of it to my
bestest stars buds how you all doing
that drab old station hanging in there
against old irons
me I just got back from the date with a
hot chick then you can guess we got what
we got up to under her extra-large
umbrella Europe is amazing one month is
in no way enough to even scratch the
surface hey thanks for the photo hey
must be them no I can't even remember
home hey must be the money okay um maybe
I'll extend my vacation for another six
months
Barry don't even think of coming to join
me wouldn't want to make all the cute
girls cry yeah so you just leave the
babes to me Jill if Claire tries to
contact you please let her know I'm okay
Chris Redfield
I think there might still be stuff in
this room that I haven't it's awesome
yeah yes I don't need you anymore do I
do I need you again anyways
what's in here grinding there is stuff
in here dude stop guys they don't know
what to do now I've got done which is
great but it doesn't really mmm
help me out much does it I think I still
need to get the heart key and I served
no no bloody clue where that could be
so just now I went into the break
oh yeah there's like something on the
second floor isn't there there's a lock
in the second time that this one
confiscation 2f waiting room I don't
know it's this one by the art room just
back over the other side did you get all
your medallions yeah oh yeah yeah so
I've done all that I've been down the
basement and back up now I've got to
find fuses and stuff I think I've got
one fuse down I'm gonna go to that
waiting room
yeah
slowly step over the dead bodies did I
get everything in that room yeah
[Music]
okay
so I need scared to the waiting room he
is it someone nearby it's very
unsettling I don't like it
life is not fair just like this game
that's another game my knees play lively
strange brother yo and he's played the
next episode soon soon I'm just slight
right maybe I'll do that tomorrow
there'll be like a nice chill one okay
bulls I think he's near where's the safe
6 to 11
okay guys 6 to 11 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8
cool
well that'll make my life a bit easier
oh yeah you still didn't get all right
why are you only getting the upgrade to
that guy that's not fair
mmm hey Josh I'm glad you're enjoying
the game play the tyrant finds you by
the way if you burn a lot when he's near
also running as well Chuckie really also
gunshots yeah yeah I knew the gunshots
thing and the zombies have to walk
around everywhere
thank you for Farah weird one ready wait
still don't know I'm going
[Music]
[Music]
maybe I have oh yeah let me have my
things but no I definitely don't let's
go back to the Clocktower then it's go
upstairs to the clock tower you can only
get her from walking upstairs right
which way
okay so that way to the balcony hot over
there this room but this is a locked
door [ __ ] what they're doing how did we
get there must be another way was that
ah where there did you do
ah thank you so much Morrison um I need
to just quickly go on YouTube to see
what you said I didn't say anything
well thank you I you so appreciate it
you cool go through the library you have
to solve the puzzle there and go to the
clock tower okay
yeah so go to the ah that's how I got to
the clock tower I went through the live
what I mean I remember now nope nope
nope
yes I know I think he's I think he's not
I think we're okay I was gonna go down
and get them Magda memo but we are okay
and to be fair we should probably just
conserve some things for now right we
got ourselves some zombies the clock
towers right down here on the right
he's around here how am I supposed to
sight he's here okay where the [ __ ]
see this is what happened to me last
time how am I supposed to concentrate on
one supposed to be doing if I've got
people chasing me all the time
how am I supposed to get that
where do I put these cogs
I don't know so many questions do you
say that
oh I just had it in the wrong bloody
place okay
I hope I don't have to write a report on
this I hope mr. freaking axe doesn't
hear that but she probably is going to
you hey look you want to sing the other
day that he doesn't get bloody while he
does he did
maybe not doesn't say it's how does this
work when does it make the noises it's
supposed to be like it's going around
the boats cuz sounds a bit weird
now these for the jail
powerpanel part yeah this must be for
downstairs in the basement right it
confuses though but I do have a fuse I
think in my little box obtained the
parking guys kick out of playing poker
just go
I thought he was gonna have to stay
looking the other way he measure this is
locked
haha it is once more this yes son
oh gosh please open a stamina
[Applause]
have nothing to stop me oh just find
this right this one Oh God not that way
[Music]
I'm gonna be saved too well you own
about a can't go in there here's a gun
if you still what I mean we're busy
Nomad tournament was my way around
it's okay
okay now Oh No there he is there he is
I don't think he comes in here is it
here that he doesn't come in Co no he
doesn't here is still stuff to pick up
in here
just let me in the room I can just move
them this way and then shoot them that
way okay I do actually already need to
find some more green herbs it's okay
why is the character taking baby steps
cuz he's hurt and this is a horror game
so if you are overpowered it would kind
of suit the purpose I guess right so
hmm
[Music]
I don't have a fuse but I've got these
two parts so yeah I'm just I just need
to get back into the basement now like
why am i storing up okay
best way to get back to the basement
I'll go upstairs to the safe that way
[Music]
it's not raining is it funny unless we
go upstairs upstairs I just keep going
up
please is he up here is he up here
[Music]
but he's not up here I'm pretty sure
yeah something else is
I regret this choice Oh
just get out let's just get out we'll go
a different way
eventually
hae-sun cat oh I guess I could go this
way I just be super Sneaky always sounds
near like you see it
no music no no no
okay
question did I so annoying
can you get the ladder down
I hope not
[ __ ] you
okay
let me come down here no it's not open
anymore okay fine
in that case done with all this crap
right
[Applause]
Wow yes this young hyperbole stop
shooting now this is how I get down to
the basement pretty sure it is but
actually Johnny said you could stun mr.
X by shooting his hand oh its head I was
like let me give you sense I read it
completely wrong
yeah I shot his hat off I don't think he
was very happy about that
here we go
wait
that way just I could really do with
some halves or something but I didn't
want to go all the way back there let's
get rid of these dogs so they stop
annoying me well say first
just in case I waste too much honor
doing it
and the tip [ __ ] the kneecaps first
there's fraud
oh wait okay so I did just waste all my
ammo but the dogs are gone oh no you
know what I don't think that was worth
it I'm just gonna run past him screw
this
you can avoid the dog for maybe in six
hours okay let's do that instead
thanks for the help guys
siga dragon or just you know nobody
running
don't tell me that they're gonna go
through the door
okay yeah this is what we need brilliant
okay so you need to be nice to killing
up that way unless this one has to be
this way yeah oh ways to both well that
doesn't even make sense that wouldn't
even be a thing
hmm
Ok Go 1 very convoluted way of doing it
[Music]
hmm
how am I gonna do this
because these both are four ways
does it really matter which way that one
[Music]
I didn't get it
go to the blue oh Jesus
right the station's swarming with
monsters even here I can hear the cries
but it's not the zombies I'm afraid of
codenamed tyrant the ultimate bioweapon
developed by those bastards at the in
the utmost secrecy to think that that
thing might be wandering around him
chances are they've ordered it to wipe
out the witnesses ah thank you that's
useful
you had a gun
I just find way too coincidental
umbrellas one of the benefactors
scholarship come on nobody cares about
that they want to know what the chief
iris big [ __ ] sinkhole in a city
which by the way rumor has it go
straight to your underground Wow
now I'm gonna talk to me or you
mmm rumors about the orphanage
interesting
finally let's move on let's move out of
this what are they after
not quite sure
maybe I'm gonna die for the first time
I loved that it was like they already
pasted out the death cuz usually it's
just like Oh fine I'm dead this is a
quick quick ass death screen okay
ah well that makes much more sense
Oh
stir it
oh my god you did it
let's not be on hon Fred
[Music]
it's freakin invincible I swear
saving your ass it's twice I didn't
realize you're keeping score look this
isn't a game nothing dies down here
No
take up keytar
yeah and this tells hoping you could
explain what's on it maybe
let's get out of it
finally she's gonna stay with us this
time yes
we might want to open the shutter
all right don't give me that attitude
should listen to the rest of it is that
the until you need it
unfortunately no Ben didn't come through
well what exactly are you looking for
more info and the people responsible for
this mess what about you it's trying to
save the world
I told lieutenant Bren I'd bring help
good luck getting up
where we going gun shop yes
going through that gun shop looks like
the only way yeah that's what's going to
get me
what a mess what I say every morning
when I wake up and look in the mirror Oh
aha what was I saying well why don't I
get anything for any of my other guns
Wow
the game listened and it granted
I mean it would be better if I could
have shotgun
[Music]
Mike I hurt you I said don't move I'm
just passing through
I'm gonna ask you to lower that weapon I
kill you I'm right back out the way you
came in needs help sir
tell me how to deal with my daughter
drop it
go wait step aside when he determinate
her before she turns
it's my [ __ ] daughter you know just
something be
mama
sweetheart I told you to stay put
so it's a slow turning process they did
was
you're a cop you're supposed to know
something how did this happen huh she
was a sweet little angel
mom I was sleeping
[Music]
it's actually birdie moves excuse some
privacy okay but can we take away any
guns in your office we'll leave you two
bullets you know it's one thing to keep
the truth from me oh why him
I want to find out what's happening here
and stuff whoever's behind it helping
people like them that's why I joined the
force
my mission is to take down on Bella's
entire operation
can you not make it out
whatever it takes to save the city count
me
in the in between the cutscenes I can
just hear my little laptop fine like a
pharmaceutical company secretly making
fire weapons wait they have a virus it
turns people into indestructible
monsters that explains the horrible
things I've seen so it's know what I'm
over here I've got everything I need you
should get yes good good good just just
making sure you know just making sure
and that's why I'm looking for a
networking she's the one at umbrella
responsible for unleashing the virus I'm
going to bring her down
this is how we get to Annette based on
what you've said the silver seems
fitting well so after you gee thanks
and imagine a real scientist being down
here come on
sewers are run by the city how could
they have a facility without the
authorities knowing
umbrellas country welcome city for years
wait that earthquake alligator right
oh you need more obviously badly well I
got some shotgun shells that's always
nice and some magum Oh
where is she are you common beach you
comment
she tell me no she's like I know she is
okay
again yeah and go where you're stuck
with me to the end
ah you sure this is the right way
unfortunately
right there
there
typical cause she didn't jump oh no am I
gonna be running towards the camera
Jesus oh wait me no it's not me is it me
[ __ ] I don't know what is it safety one
straight down the middle what now I
don't know you sure this is the right
way unfortunately hey fritz and Vignesh
go Silla
stay on the side and said I can't access
these stay on the side
[Music]
[Music]
now what race is how I should be on up
here
just get up here
cool that was fun I enjoyed that fun
that was you said the virus turned
people into monsters not reptiles fair
point I'm just impressed I made it in
one piece
well I mean it did die once you gotta
press button or or shall I
so let me get this straight umbrella
sells monsters like that
to who our military somebody else's I
don't sell the monsters they sell the
viruses that make them and and that is
who makes the viruses scary that
alligator was Annette is far more
dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
save point
I gotta find yourself that Birkin she's
who we're looking at she is not much
time need to dispose of it we're here
for the g-virus
that's not gonna happen I'm warning the
doctor oh yeah
Hey
didn't expect that from a scientist Leon
fair enough scientists just go stop her
before she gets away
I'm right outside the facility a pursuit
of a mint
ah it's not on her but she gave him her
coat thank you
once it's in here I'll coughing stretch
you can look at me she's so fat I stood
all in heels
oh well I guess I better write is there
anything else look at my booty a
appreciate
what is that oh cool
so I can't get that way so I've gotta go
that way
what does she happen she just saved
again
I can track wiring and hack electronic
it could mean okay
secret weapon time
okay what do they even do
not so sure what my goal is here one way
of Oddi just kind of fold through the
fans but sure blow it up why not if you
can why not
hmm
that's about to mess up my me just
[Music]
I already put in a request last week but
we absolutely must have a replacement ID
verse one ASAP we need one to gain
access to certain areas of the main
facility in other words me and my crew
can't get to the places we need to in
order to do our job right now so I don't
want to hear anyone you need to go
ah
oh nice okay cool ammo
all right you just said I like how long
fire hydrants
everyone oh Jesus
he's just dying
oh Jesus Christ I hate you something
happens something happens something
happens at the end what happened
[Music]
[Music]
nothing else around to screw it
oh my gosh these guess himself those
shoes
you keep you always been good at running
ahead
yeah buck
I've got like no ammo left you do
realize this night you're gonna have to
just save one bullet for her wait are
you trying to kill her
I totally forgot the head to use my
things come on
oh no now I need to turn up again oh it
doesn't matter
I'm totally dead now
mine it's hard to play sir
ah
ah where is it ah somewhere
come on no [ __ ]
no no I'm gonna just keep going around
oh this is odd oh thank god right
really I'll save on a different one just
in case I'm like actually this is
ridiculous
wait I thought I could see a zombie
outline I was like that's cool if I can
see zombies ooh balls they'll give me a
little bit more advantage I just
realized you can't see me huh my head
let's go
to be found just looking for some health
with the new wristband that's just
arrived we can finally begin our survey
of the demolition area as to the report
from the other day about the incinerator
it's nothing really
probably just a large piece of leftover
trash I'll go take a look myself after a
wrap-up the support
I know you're severely hurt I'm sorry
this is all my fault
wish that would give me like a little
bit of house just anything please give
me help okay so there's nothing around
here and no health or anything that's
fantastic there's a lot of folks who say
hmm
when we go in with this
go in here
so that one's connected to that door
which is connected to that thing up
there which is also connected to this
thing these doors
but none of them are actual power
supplies there was this thing down there
how do we get there no cuz that's just
what the bloody hell am i doing why me
there's nothing down here
avoid dying
let's go back up the stairs
Oh anyway okay fair enough I thought
let's power up it was already bad
Hey Dude trust you Bravo gonna burn your
life now you'll never get your filthy
hands on the G I'm not the only one
after it
realistic
Oh
Oh
the different ones
oh and have to BBC
I wasted too much time
no God I'm not gonna make it
out dead already and then you need don't
cook to life for a few seconds I'm sorry
I D is October 1st
please return a pair of this date not
gonna happen
please may I have her
you know does she not get anyhow like
[ __ ] this is hard I'm like one-hit
dead right now
at least you guys are happy that I got
out of that alive they give a lot of
extra time yeah like 30 seconds extra Oh
Jason
enough this cat-and-mouse game the game
is over
I love how in the cutscene so she's
she's still fine she's doubled
tell me
your husband's still alive
or did you kill him so you could take
credit for tea interesting theory
you don't walk
over my dead body
yeah now she's definitely near death
like if she wasn't she is now
he's sleeping with your coat what was
that noise
okay now I'm gonna be back somebody on
again
yeah with a generator the way that I saw
it was that it was like heating up to
cook you and then it started to cook
that's the logic that I got from that
with the big oven
heydo
dammit where's her coat
you ought to give it back to her don't
just leave it there where's our crew huh
Duncan sees vada where are you
there it is
give it back to her you can't just leave
it there
so how are you gonna get out cuz you
can't get up it's broken
do we have a map what she says with the
map up now I mean like when did we pick
this up
oh okay dresser
anything good in here nasty
mr. became there we actually going back
in there
I guess okay that's a pleasant smell
is not what the rule is Ryan
ah okay right
it's a find something to turn this we
don't have anything you know storage do
any night of every day
ah Jackson Jack I totally understand
that you want to play this game before
watching it that makes complete sense I
hope you get to play it soon it's very
good trio left or right hmm not all
right guides you choose left or right
left or right Bastien why do you choose
I'm gonna pop to the toilet so I'll be
right back and you let me know in the
comments
left or right
yep I felt the mute was to them so I
went right that's that's what you missed
I'm saying going left right left right
left right and then I was like oh I'm
gonna go back and try out for left
anyway
yes that's why I went
and one of the windows don't change
you're like out of Mike's door sorry
please don't get up
what's happening let's have a film night
I actually love I don't know why but I
love like watching film watching metal
videos in games like
CCTV and stuff I just get excited by the
small things wait I honestly when I was
a kid I used to play this game called uh
auntie boo Adventureland it helped me
with math and stuff but they had this
part where it was just videos and it was
like little rhymes and stuff and I
literally used to get popcorn and I used
to like hang up a towel and make it like
a screen area cuz the computer was under
the stairs and I used to my own personal
cinema I had so much fun I had so much
free time as a kid
No
I can hear something where is it oh my
god died you know II just
I thought that was
why do we even bother without them
let's get over there
I don't really know why I could take
that out I feel like I did that part
wrong
hmm
Oh
can we get under here
so energy on this
where are you he down I go
literally
this is where I started
oh is that a liquor guys everyone plays
I was a little I think it was
oh my gosh what is that
I do not wanted to serve that blah
there was no piece of flesh and drained
I was like no it's not liquor it's worth
thanks now we read it yep thanks flag
cable-car interesting
umbrella called privation
where'd she go
nice
days be something in here yes
I mean if someone has like loads of free
time and that she just guesses that
recombination and gets it right that
would be pretty cool stuff
oh maybe this there are alarms going off
all over nest I don't know what's going
on but I can hear gunfire and I can't
reach my section chief we're trapped
please send help director Owens the
situation here is dire nest has been
contaminated with the virus it's
unbelievable the failsafe system didn't
activate at all is this the work of
outsiders I can't imagine who else it
would be but why
mayor Kent mayor and Kim are dead I
can't stop coughing why won't you answer
me and director Owens you it was all up
hmm there any kind of glue in there as
to perhaps would like a bee and he asks
me no nest
so if I was a cheater oh just look on
the internet what about what the name
was
Owens stoic - Owens
Toby look over there anyway
the letter cap to open it cap
their letter tap
oh the letter cap the letters cap a sure
oh there's no see a is no unless it's
nope is literally carried out
okay well I guess we'll have to carry on
without them
I like the sound of that
hey des
I'm coming ADA
naive
Oh damnit so under 7 s said s our our
drained all said I can come back later
that's okay then I'm just getting my
name of the landing grating for the CEO
thank you for your interest in Knights
Construction Companies over the past 20
years we have had the honor to work on
the sewer systems of some of our
country's greatest cities while never
losing sight of our core our two core
principles of playfulness and superior
industrial design I KCT we believe that
just because our work is subterra
subterranean doesn't mean our designs
have to be safar what we defined than a
queen will polish their night and as
pleasant as a fawn our work is short to
bring great victory to everyone involved
maybe your meet on the field Sunday
and you guys ready to maybe wait wait
one sec let me just see if I can find
anything else that might be good and
useful I mean there's a save point
I'm guessing that's just
huh what is all this
love things okay well we'll come back
here in a bit let's watch them if you
watch the tape
what
what I've been stupid where the hell we
did pick up a tape right
the hell
what happened to that
I am actually very confused right now
what I'm not questioning everything
did I pick it up did I just look at it
and not pick it up I did pick it up
right guys went to the lighter pink
written to the line to like come back
around so you can tell me and you can be
like new you're an idiot you never
actually put to go I've got Matt right
so tight later I sandbox video player
where's the video I thought I picked it
up oh my god did I pick it up freaking
idiot
why is it still that
great
oh what's that
okay so what are the all this day
I lost something that tells you how to
unlock the door in the you a in the you
area during the last mad dash of the
transfer and there you have to stick one
plug into each terminal but if anyone
remembers which book was where I please
be a power and share personally info on
the board
pretty sure the rook and knight on the
same war and the bishop and queen ants
next to each other the queen and
workhorse at opposite each other -
because I do need that that piece back
at the other place
I don't want pick any of them up now so
that I don't need them right now
okay
Oh
I didn't did this flooring I got so
excited about the tape but I just
started to talk about how excited it was
but I didn't actually put it in my
inventory Wow we all go means go back
that way anyway let's go check this out
tonight let's put that badge away don't
need it
Hey
well then you don't really work on your
own I need to get you with other things
I was just a light
the item below is delivered to the
location specified in your order he was
isn't safe accommodation is written on
the side of it safe in chalk
please remember to erase it before you
use the safe okay where's the safe
heat-resistant safe IV you stand for
cable entry so we need to meet up with
ADA hey thanks for the follow
you actually dad are you just told me
yeah yourself away to
12-8 no wait
one two one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve one
two up to twelve eight yeah one two one
two three four five six seven eight
still messed up the beginning
very nice
even to Jesus dumb as taking on God's
against poison
are we doing it this way
hi zombie
just what you doing down there beer
bottles here drinking on the job you
guys so angry
[Music]
yeah not to you sure but it just did but
I think it was a good thing what did I
just do
oh I must've
opened a door in the sewer I think
[Music]
Jesus bracelet just like everywhere
sanity this side
cool
nope see ya
okay now I can find it anything
[Music]
I am highly not okay with it cold will
that make my decision easier I'm going
this way
Oh oh yeah so what was this one again
asked me Jo something s me just go said
it was
that's Jay
would you guys say it was Wolfram pixels
the middle play this so I'm just a
scared
fair enough yeah I can't I mean I'm just
cheating anyway but running solve this
son of SX something and that's it
literally won't open until you find the
clue to go with it
SZ f yeah thank you he said that
Morrison thank you thank you thank you
anyway this is not really where we want
to go either
I think we actually do need to go in
this so it's but I need to make some
room for stuff so I'm gonna bits of
stuff and
and yeah
so don't don't need this anymore I'm not
using the planks here keep this handy Oh
watch me you Sabourin
[Music]
I just want to find the tapes that sort
of Brady care about lungs something
all right back out again what Legion
says keep the badge now I have like no
spaces I don't want to cuz I want to
pick up stuff
Oh carnea do you have to keep but I need
some room because I need to pick well I
know I need to pick up at least the
cassette store oh wait I can combine new
dirt
fine Wow something - so it's other
stores for now this apparently okay I
listened to your lesion
yes angry zombies down here does
anything up right here checking every
nook and cranny for ammo
montage you could never overstay your
visit don't be silly
yes so can I use this to open this door
hey are you actually good ha ah I
thought you need a handle I guess it is
a handy watch me
my hobby
oh that it's cool that looks super
creepy I love it
we've got ourselves a key
I don't wanna go but there's a half
though let's go up a FS
is there anything even down there and
what the herb and what the herb I can't
even get this way anyway
all right bye fritz thanks for coming
oh oh Jesus hell was that I don't know
well let's just get up come on dude get
up get up
I'm summing X and he's not getting up
you know there's an icon there that
means that like I should be right
okay
am I being stupid here all right
Oh
that was an old place I'm sure that's
probably doesn't pick up this is getting
worse Oh
down point I see you know it's a pile of
points
you're disgusted
sorry but you are
you know I'm gonna let you get me I've
got a nice
where is your own
where's your eyes
I made it somehow they don't even give
me armor on the other side it's not fair
you have to shoot the eye I know but
where was his eye though wasn't there
it's probably on the other side of his
body that he couldn't get to
No
right
to actually want
okay I'm just
hmmm so many what does
goodbye
[Music]
nice
all I can say
I'll discard this one
you ready I hope this open up
whatever course leave them
keep the chess pieces but how can I get
back out by not how can I get back out
didn't I have to yes as this one is that
one button
if I played this game in a dark room
though you guys wouldn't see my
reactions yeah hold the bloody how am I
supposed to keep these chess pieces and
get back up those stairs
I don't think I can
yeah guys I I'm pretty sure I have to
put it back in
these are just says yes I'm not quite
sure what the yes is to the problem with
that I don't know little ways open yeah
on about middle way open
I honestly I don't know unless I'm just
being an absolute idiot but I really
can't see a way around this cuz I I need
to get in this door see from this surah
can get out right but I need this door
open to get into here in the first place
and then my other one is in here and if
I take that out then this is gonna lock
me and that's like and I put one in
there and I thought that was gonna open
that one
but it didn't open it watch this is what
it does that man I thought this one was
gonna open this game this year it seems
logical right but nope it stays shut it
it's enough so I don't even know what
this one does really go through the door
yeah I know I'm just trying to say that
I need I can't go through the door and
not take these with me no I mean I can't
go through the door and take these with
me it's impossible because I can't get
to the ball you know I mean unless what
I am missing camping
well I'm sure well I know I can come
back anyway
so I got myself a new gun it's fun but
these plug sockets having a red herb
when I went the video weight although
everybody should not waste my ammo on
you okay so I'm gonna go this way please
find a way out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Lexi is a glowing fire relay up here
Thank You game for that lovely bit of
design so I could see there was
something into this is something this is
the end of this one too unless they
already go to my book
oh is this nothing
so many of them
hmm max like run run don't look back
um where do I went together uh I think I
have to go this way
yeah wait have I been to lift work room
less all right I can gather
I like this plane fare though makes life
a little bit easier for me
violation why is typo telling me to go
back I just want the cassette
where's your eye there it is
god
well that flame through a ran out pretty
quickly you have to collect the terse
pieces I know but I I ran through this
for like 10 minutes about how I did not
see a way of getting back out with the
chess pieces plus the yeah I don't have
enough space of the meter wait Oh need
to get back up
I need skill up up up how do I get up
wait
he's got up this side
Oh
alright Seattle Nathan I didn't realize
you're still here
good situation
Oh guys I just want to get back up to
the cassette I'm just very pleased with
where I am how'd it get there
there's no way I'm getting up because
you're being lost in the sewers oh
absolutely
here again that's you
oh don't worry Johnny I wasn't gonna
throw away the key I was just expecting
ya expecting it and inspecting it to see
exactly what it was they told us
I could get rid of some of these guns
I don't even have the ammo for them
okay so there is yet
are you actually dead are you do it do
it
I'm doing I knew it I knew it yes that's
perfect that's such perfect timing
thank you so much I needed that so badly
okay great
there's files we're under yet
no I can't read them I can't read them
there's nothing here I got it
yeah he's definitely around waiting for
me yeah maybe maybe nice thing was not
the best mini air there's a plug lookit
it was across here wasn't it that wasn't
it was back here
wait oh is this the key
[Music]
Oh perfect
that's my shotgun hi
noise
I mean I'm glad I came in here well
shotgun ammo is always nice
you're ready for Diez
there we go okay cool and now we may
so we're just going on
I don't worry Mac his head blew up so
we're fine
Jazz Festival flyer ah SCF thanks guys
[Music]
[Music]
wait I feel like I should probably
before you do that go and get this
you should I just got it don't already
want to ask for a bit I'll just come
back there get it
wasn't evil seven has taught me that a
blown head does not equal to a Deadhead
Oh deadhead dead no that's major I mean
this game is good but that game was
something else thought that was like my
type of heart and you know this is gonna
go back to its roots which is nice
Oh apparently we won't sounds like me
thank you very much
why do you want to go now not that way
that's back upstairs but we do have a
team on hand as well well we'll just go
up here to like Johnson finger you know
oh yeah don't need
I don't know why but I never want to
discard things so I just always story
just worried the games gonna trick me
[Music]
and they combine these with this
I mean I don't have any much
flamethrower anyway now I'm much
All Right see you later montage thanks
for coming oh and have fun doing your
web dev
so any point going back this way again
it's a glass in the past
by that I mean last week
yeah okay fair enough
everyone I know Leon's ill by the way I
just like to watch him suffer okay
hmm oh my god no I didn't
but it looked so much like it was going
to work it fit the shape ok Johnny I'll
go watch the tape it's gonna get back
there
Thank You officer neva to
you can see already opened OT so to get
back to the room that I need to go to
you
where's that slashed off oh it's just oh
it's a shame
all right and then go back around here
right I think so
we're somewhere
nope yeah
I also have a chess piece that night
plug it's not a nice this
just put me there for now
now let's finally watch this tape
please stop
oh I'll bet those rats spread it
wait
this game is seats it's Allah all the
specs are on Steam if you want to see if
you can run in
or received with gold console
so I need to get at least two more and
we know there's two in that room I just
don't really know how I can get out with
both of them
and what else did we go
he apparently I needed this was
something we don't know what and he did
it for
okay
okay tie ball move we shall go back to
that room
use the dongle for computer access I did
that ages ago is that all it's useful
because it doesn't have the you stick
oh that's a good cool just can you
retract the USB that is a good cool
Vignesh maybe you can do okay hold up
I'm going back
oh I just have to remember my way
everyone
I'm not feeding him Mack he has to just
Brit his teeth and bathroo it he's not
hurt enough
oh thank you so much for Nash
I don't know why but the button noise
just sounds really out of place okay I
remember how it is not nice
dick Nash
yes in the chop
thank you
laughter the fresh mountain
oh my god I'm getting lost
I'm just gonna keep learning around I'm
sure I'll find it at some point have to
know what does my round circle
oh sorry Dustin I thought Vignesh did it
as well
maybe you both get it but thank you
Dustin
oh yeah now I remember
you
oh yeah not that way just me who does
that
No oh sorry I feel bad I don't know
sorry I worry too much
[Music]
okay so let's think about how we can get
out with these guys
our Johnny did that before to good
ground not the only one who tried to get
up the jump down point okay so if I take
that one out that's gonna close but I
mean no get dropped in this bar
this one I can't give us that door
so I can jump down many sentient bugs
for certain doors so I need the Queen
flood which is not this one which is why
I wasn't working don't we dip dip dip
okay I still need to get out
now
ah perfect I did part of my belt yes
puzzle succeeded
let's go back progress
I still feel bad about getting the name
on Dustin I'm sorry
I try
okay
[Music]
keep thinking the pink fleshy parts
a mystical game
oh they know how to get you yeah I think
now it's probably the time I can allow
you to eat something to make yourself a
little bit
okay but so now we have
these guys and now we can sort out the
puzzle but you know what's gonna make my
life so much easier but I think you're
just holding all at once so noticed oh I
can just discard this anyway
okay so I have all the pieces here
we know that this one goes here
the night goes here
not the only ones we have references
and it says here the book and nights are
on the same wall the bishop and queen
ants next to each other the Queen and
Brooke were opposite each other too
rook and Knight on same one so it's
gonna be on
but Queen is opposite it and queen is
not mr. Bishop
so the Queen can't be
in the middle well and that's the
patientís on this one
Bishop's gotta be on this one man
it's king
that's the bishop right
rook and Knight say well bishop and
queen aren't next to each other Queen
and Brooke are opposite each other and
queen
that is definitely the brook right and
that's the bishop yes
we know that's the king yeah fun fact
last time I played chess I was in his
Star Wars themed pub it was grand anyway
um
it was super fun it was largely amazing
there's like 10th bit with them big
pillows and just like chess and checkers
and it was good Queen Anne what's not
next to it to each other again the
bishop and queen ant next
see the Bishop's gotta be gay and their
kings on the other side
hopefully they're younger Muttley almost
area oh wait let's sleep again
look I don't mean touching something yes
we can get it back
Jockamo get some more ammo for the
it was the time cuz I'm getting hungry
hangry oh my gosh okay I'm gonna go soon
I think probably should yes most likely
probably most definitely
[Music]
what's in this room
it's worked for me last time no
yeah
Jesus Christ
huh
[Music]
get out
[Music]
whoa those stupid
[Music]
no I refuse game a review
don't you [ __ ]
[Music]
do you have another eye
[Music]
[Music]
now I got you
[Music]
okay now I know it's do not that not
that
I know IRA can be so much cooler you got
to like roll and stuff but I know why
not
[Music]
finally I should miss that one that's
good Yomi
now I got you I need to get out of the
way though
I thought I was hidden under the thing
there's a specific place that you need
to stand to make sure you're out the way
using logic I'm going back to the edge
of it will not help you this time okay
game
do what you tell me to face the way you
want me to play
even though he's been now I got you
what am i doing just anyway
wait he's still alive oh my god
let's do this
Oh
please dad please let's hope that's the
last of them mm-hmm oh and it made me
I'm nice never walk away to the door
how convenient Eric you need to do it 10
times
oh no I didn't look around for us I
didn't know was gonna make cutscene
hello hey da a tour are you over here
oh she is getting worried there for a
second I can't get it out I don't know
if I should ever just do it I can't walk
like this
Oh
I can do it myself just relax okay
so what do we do now
get yourself out of here
but you still can I'm not just gonna
leave you not like this
you don't understand
situations worse than I thought
not getting realities
rejected me xiaoxi Kaz guys Munter
realized we were keeping score
yes we broke through the hard exterior
how much will burn through her shell
push it working just right out what's
your step you wanna help
we have to get to the nest nest
umbrellas lab like when you'd best not
let it slip that's where the virus
samples are you up for this
any effort in my schedule come on
why does he flirt with like everyone yes
ma'am
first plan now hire he's just like just
come help himself
honey oh good look around here anyway
okay let's get to the nest you've got
the bracelet Estanza nest our wristbands
our ticket to ride
yeah nice where'd you get that right
priority anyway we're almost there
everybody should go to meet myself since
aids up almost bad like she said quite
frankly I don't want see so dishonest he
is the first guy first
I mean first game in a long time I
haven't stopped playing to go in me
carry no eat that only make me feel
worse most a time my need for food is
great to them the game that this game
I'll children's worse than it looks what
a pair both got one foot in the Braves
[Music]
yeah we know that should take us where
we need to go Johnny says gets pretty
hard from here okay before we stop at
the next safe yeah why not
this trend is done burlesque do not exit
until the final destination
you know what I was thinking I can't
wait for the FBI to raid umbrella
headquarters and take those bastards to
justice
I agree but to be clear you're not
working in official capacity this is a
federal case once we get the g-virus I'm
back on my own hey Leon trust me
trust me
honestly
right I thought I might get your help
and I was right if you can secure the
g-virus
I can make sure what happened in record
in the city never happens again
yeah
sit yourself it's a federal case I don't
want Authority look at me
I'm a liability now
I'm gonna finish this case you're the
last time I've got much it'll leave you
here with your tack work you need help
we definitely broke through
don't worry about me
I got to see this through
I got plenty live for
now go please we don't have much time
you're gonna need this
okay
beyond
I know
yeah don't worry about putting pressure
on him because you can't do your job
anymore just cuz you kissed him do you
actually know it does
I think I might still need that one get
ready Oh God okay I think I'm just going
to save and then go for dinner
oh that wasn't autosave I'll see what's
in here but guys I am going to be
leaving very very soon and Jack waiting
for CT can't remember I've got some play
food videos though it wasn't c4 you've
got to find like an electric box
it's not true
oh my gosh how many doors
doesn't it look good creature with eyes
and a big mouth like okay I wonder where
the g-virus is not room there was a room
that's so cool wanly never left so he's
probably still in the NAP room that's
one long nap you got there
well let's go in here ah savor nice do
we have a muffin around because that
would
no Maps authorized slap only beyond this
whole must refrain from injury blood on
the bed where is it
cute umbrella yes okay so you've got our
map you were already there is the NAP
room I kind of want to go to the NAP
room just just the pizza
there's something cool happening on the
security cameras
I'm saved again
I think just quickly run to the bathroom
there's so much Brad
my god is that enough room in this
cafeteria
yeah this is
huh his design for your attritional
rules really is biological research
I don't know I know he gets buried
attrition action of healthy foods help
me I've got Jesus Christ
[Music]
[Music]
where are the
nice
okay I'm not too sure to go so this is
the perfect place to end it yeah anyway
that is where I'm gonna say goodbye
thank you very much for watching another
really fun playthrough probably play
some more
next Saturday if not after work doing